ever since we started periodic videos
we've wanted these videos to be used by
school teachers to help their class
understand chemistry and now by
collaborating with ted-ed we have come
up with a way which I hope you will find
really useful if you're a school teacher
and quite fun if you're a pupil or just
somebody at home because you don't have
to be teacher to use this we've produced
a whole periodic table of questions one
set of questions about each element on
the periodic table based on our video
and what is nice about the ted-ed system
is that once you're registered if you
don't like our questions you can write
your own and use them for your class or
use them on your friends so it's a
completely tunable system to your needs
and it will help we hope use our videos
in whatever educational contents you
want you can even write the questions in
completely different languages from
English this has been a collaboration
between Nottingham and the university of
girona who sent a student who helped us
do the background research for doing
these questions so thank you very much
Penton we're really grateful to you and
also to the guys at ted aid who have
helped us set this up